The earth was juvenile, barren in its infancy, then from dust and darkness, the lifeless
silence was broken, the crust of the earth cracked and moored, and from the bed of creation
within it rose the first family.
Upon seeing the empty earth, they used the immeasurable power within themselves to form
beauty in an empty canvas of the land.
They lit the sky with stars, pulled the mountains from the ground, and filled craters with oceans.
Among the divines, the sister Azira would colour the land's invertency, fill the blue
oceans with life, and instil within these creations the potential to grow and repopulate.
In her accomplishment, she would be known as the Goddess of Fertility.
In time, Azira's creations would grow in intellect and complexity.
From their scattered tribes, the gods took to guiding humanity with their superior knowledge.
In this exchange, humanity gave them worship and devotion, the gods would shape the foundations
of human civilization across the land in each celebrating their divine benefactor.
The gods, confident that mankind could stand on their own, sought to create the heavens,
a place where the gods could raise families of their own kind, as earth was no space for
them to grow.
They rightfully seeked the same prosperity that they offered for their own and left.
Out of all the gods, it was Azira who could not leave humanity.
She loved her creations, yet she also loved the gods.
She left a piece of her divinity with her family in remembrance and remained on earth
to live among humanity, not as a ruler, but as a watcher and caretaker.
It would be after the gods departure that the long peace would end.
With the imbalance of power, wars between the regions could not be prevented.
Anger, strife, and hunger for power would taint the ego of man, and Azira's limited
power could not restore the will the gods had left behind for humanity.
In her perceived failure, Azira would seemingly disappear from the walks of history.
It has been long theorized that the goddess still lives amongst us in secret.
There has been a long time speculation that, throughout history, Azira has been guiding
humanity in small leadership roles, humanitarian efforts in philanthropy, or using her power
to prevent cataclysmic disasters.
However she is, we can all rest easy that she is watching over us from a position befitting
a goddess among men.
Well, Billy, I think we all learned an important lesson here today.
That's right, Papa.
Whatever happens, we're all family.
That's exactly right, Billy, and there's nothing more important than family.
Oh, shucks.
I'm so happy I have such a big happy loving family.
I'd be such a sucker if I didn't have a family.
Aw, Billy.
It has been a few years since I came to the realization that I could no longer outrun
the reach of mankind.
Living among animals, I tried to run from civilization for as long as time would allow.
I am content to play the role of a commoner among humanity, yet I am tortured still by
loneliness, by desires.
I cannot fight my needs anymore.
I must find my place among the humans and start a family.
In my inaugural efforts to integrate into modern society, it became clear that I lack
the necessary knowledge to fraternize as humans do.
With animals, it's so simple, yet with humans, my knowledge avails me no aid.
Again and again, I accumulated countless attempts at courting a suitable mate.
How could I, before my goddess of fertility, struggle in this venture?
Yet seeing the progress humanity has earned themselves, astounds me.
They have become creators in themselves, expanding upon the earth we had given them.
The tiny seed I had planted all those eons ago, well how it blossomed.
I had believed my heart broken beyond repair, but living as they do, I see now, I see now,
that they don't need the wills of higher beings to find their own happiness.
Perhaps this, in itself, was the will of the gods.
I see now the beauty in the human spirit, for all its ugliness and evil, but also in its kindness and community.
It is the dichotomy of these aspects that makes them worthy of my love.
I only regret not growing alongside them.
I must make up for lost time, for every kindling of my passion.
I have found, I have endless love to give, and give it a shell.
Any takers?